Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Comment en est-on arrivé là ?
Je voulais être pirate, en fait.
Je voulais être pirate-découvreur.
Le marin solitaire ne peut pas
être bon partout,
mais on n’a pas le droit d’être
mauvais quelque part.
Fast but not furious.
Les expériences d'équipage
sont incroyables.
C'est une aventure humaine géniale.
Pour l’instant, tempête,
en espérant que ça reste
comme ça jusqu’au bout.
Je n'ai jamais aimé les choses faciles,
mais j'aime bien les rendre faciles.
Dans la Coupe, ce qui est impressionnant,
c’est l’immersion totale dans un projet.
On est dedans complètement.
À la question :
comment j’en suis arrivé là ?
Je n’y suis pas encore arrivé.
Pas du tout.
Loïck Peyron : Bonsoir tout le monde !
Sandrine Quétier : « Sans filet »,
c’est le thème que vous avez choisi.
Je me suis interrogée et j’ai regardé
la définition de « Sans filet ».
Cher Loïck, j’ai lu :
« Équilibriste, sans protection,
sans garantie. »
Or il me semble qu’un marin a besoin
en permanence de sa ligne de vie,
que les filets font partie constituante
des multicoques.
Après une cinquantaine de traversées
de l’Atlantique, quelques tours du monde,
après avoir gagné la Route du Rhum 2014,
je reste dubitative.
Oui, vraiment, j’ai du mal à croire
que l’on puisse vivre sa vie sans filet.
Comment,
cher Loïck, avec tout le respect
que je vous dois,
comment, à 62 ans, pouvez-vous dire encore
que vous vivez et que vous avez
vécu sans filet ?
Pardonnez-moi, Loïck,
mais je n’y crois qu’à moitié.
LP : Moi aussi, je n’y crois qu’à moitié.
Mais on ne peut pas avoir 100 %
tort ou raison.
Il faut un peu de filet, de protection,
de préparation, vraisemblablement,
et de l’anticipation.
Mais ce que j’aime bien
et ce que j’ai essayé de faire,
et vraisemblablement aidé énormément
par une éducation qui nous a poussés,
mes frères et sœurs, dans cette voie-là,
c’est de créer mes filets moi-même,
qu’on ne me les impose pas.
C’est un peu la grande malheureuse
décadence de ce monde moderne,
c’est qu’on nous impose
de plus en plus les filets.
Les protections, les principes
de précaution sont intéressants, certes,
mais ils sont très difficiles à définir.
Quelques exemples : vous êtes tous
plus ou moins venus en train.
A chaque arrêt maintenant,
et depuis quelques années,
on vous prévient qu’il y a un espace
entre le marchepied et le quai.
On est d’accord ?
À chaque arrêt
et c’est même répété deux fois.
Qu’est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Ça nous infantilise totalement.
Mes premières transatlantiques,
je les ai faites vraiment sans filet.
Je ne savais même pas où j’étais.
J’avais un sextant,
ma bite et mon couteau,
ce sont les trois instruments
importants à bord d’un bateau.
Et pour les femmes, c'est pareil.
Sur le même bateau, le même petit jaune,
vous souvenez-vous de cette Route du Rhum,
il y a quatre ans, à l’ancienne,
sur un vieux bateau.
Voilà, 40 ans après, sur le même bateau,
avec pas mal plus de bouteille,
on m’a imposé un matériel
de sécurité incomparable,
incomparablement supérieur
et souvent superflu.
C’est ça ce que je veux dire
dans le « sans filet » -
quand on a la chance
de pouvoir s’exprimer -
prendre des risques mais en les analysant,
ce n’est pas être casse-cou -
ça ne m’intéresse pas du tout.
C’est d’analyser -
SQ : Vous ne parlez pas de goût du risque,
mais du goût de la gestion du risque.
LP : C’est ça qui est passionnant
quand on a la chance de pouvoir
le faire, de s’exposer.
Ce n’est pas du tout de vouloir chavirer
toutes les cinq minutes qui m’intéresse.
Preuve en est, et je touche du bois,
mais je suis l’un des rares marins
à avoir fait autant de multicoque
en solitaire sans jamais chavirer.
On est très, très peu
dans ce petit village.
Pourquoi ? Parce que justement,
c’est la gestion, le dosage.
Je dis souvent qu’oser, tout le monde
peut faire et devrait,
mais doser, peu de gens savent faire ça.
C’est le dosage en toutes choses qui
va nous différencier vraisemblablement,
c’est le dosage dans tous les domaines,
industriel, économique, militaire.
C’est tout le problème
en ce moment : le dosage.
SQ : Sans filet, le dosage,
je me demande comment on acquiert tout ça,
comment on acquiert justement
cette capacité à doser.
Et sans filet, ça voudrait dire
par exemple avoir confiance,
avoir confiance en soi,
avoir confiance en la vie.
Est-ce que c’est une façon de lâcher prise
sur ce qu’on ne peut pas maîtriser ?
LP : La notion de confiance
est assez étonnante.
Il faut avoir confiance en son intuition.
Quand on est en mer, on passe
son temps à changer d’avis.
Je trouve que changer d'avis,
c'est très intéressant.
La fameuse stratégie d’un marin,
c’est constamment de virer de bord.
Quand on dit d’un politique
qu’il vire de bord,
on trouve qu’il a renié une grande
partie des gens qui croyaient
que c’était le bon chemin.
Mais ce n’est pas toujours idiot
d’adapter ou d’observer la concurrence.
La confiance, c’est essentiellement
la confiance dans son intuition.
Quand on est jeune et qu’on a la chance
d’être largué sur un petit bateau -
Le bateau, tout le monde l’a dit ici,
la voile, la mer au sens large,
est une école de vie assez exceptionnelle,
quand on a la chance de pouvoir le faire.
Peu importe la taille du bateau,
la taille des oreilles ne fait pas
qu’on entend mieux,
le plus grand trimaran du monde ne fait
pas de nous le meilleur marin du monde.
La bonne nouvelle : ce n’est pas
une question de vitesse,
c’est une question d’autonomie.
Regardez le regard des enfants dont
vous posez le cul dans un Optimist :
c’est leur premier sentiment de liberté,
c’est la première fois qu’ils
dirigent eux-mêmes leur vie.
C’est la même chose en vélo.
Il faut travailler cette intuition.
Il faut lui faire confiance.
SQ : Je pense par exemple à cette anecdote
quand vous avez quatorze ans,
que vous pilotez le bateau de vacanciers.
Je me demande ce qu’il peut bien se passer
dans la tête d’un gamin de quatorze ans
qui dit à ces vacanciers :
«Vous allez là, moi,
je maîtrise le reste.»
Racontez-nous cette anecdote, Loïck,
qui est très surprenante.
LP : Ça part de la baie de La Baule
et du Pouliguen.
On a la chance avec notre papa,
le commandant Peyron,
il a les mêmes sourcils que moi et donc,
une autorité naturelle assez étonnante,
on habite au bord de l’eau, coup de bol,
et on fait du dériveur.
Depuis tout petit, avec mes frères
et parfois seul, j’ai souvent fait ça.
J’ai eu la chance,
et la confiance totale de mes parents,
de prendre le petit bateau familial
qui est dans le port du Pouliguen.
Donc depuis très jeune
et tout seul, en solitaire.
Le solitaire était quelque chose -
On est dans les années 60,
Tabarly vient de gagner une transat en 64,
Là, j’ai quatre ans.
Mon oncle, Jean-Yves Terlain,
va faire la transat en 72.
Alain Colas, tout ça fait partie
de mon environnement.
Le solitaire, à l’époque, en France,
devient une spécialité française,
et il l’est encore aujourd’hui
très clairement.
Je n’ai qu’une envie,
c’est d’être tout seul sur un bateau.
SQ : Et vos parents vous font confiance ?
LP : Exactement.
L’éducation de nos parents -
c’est bizarre car on parle
souvent de cette histoire.
ce n’est pas parce que Maman
est dans la salle - merci Maman -
mais il est vrai que la manière de nous
élever était très intéressante.
Par exemple, quand on est en croisière
avec le commandant Peyron,
capitaine d’un des plus gros pétroliers
du monde, et on lui demande où on est,
il nous dit de regarder la carte.
Donc, aucun assistanat.
Il y a juste un environnement extrêmement
positif qui nous pousse à nous démener.
Tout ça fait que, à l’âge de 14 ans,
je me retrouve skippeur
ou du moins responsable
d’un bateau de croisière.
J’emmène des clients qui, pour moi,
sont des adultes et fortunés,
et moi, je n’ai pas un centime,
mais je suis chef.
On ramène un bateau des Baléares
et on se retrouve dans une grosse tempête
du côté du Cap de Creus, Cadaqués
C’est un coin pas terrible
en termes de vagues -
ça ne vaut pas le Vendée Globe
entre Kevin et Jean Le Cam -
mais ça peut être aussi dangereux.
À bord, j’ai trois adultes
morts de trouille.
Je suis sur le pont presque jour
et nuit, ça va durer 24 heures.
Et un moment, je lâche la barre.
Je leur ai dit de ne plus aller sur
le pont maintenant pour bricoler un truc.
Mais je l’amarre, je sais comment
équilibrer un bateau seul, tout va bien.
SQ : Eux, ils sont dans quel état ?
LP : Ils paniquent.
Deux choses intéressantes là-dessus :
un des adultes me sort sa carte bleue.
J’ai 14 ans.
il me sort sa carte bleue et me dit :
«Tu me sors d’ici, appelle
un porte-avions, un hélico.»
Il veut partir d'ici.
Génial, le pouvoir d’un môme de 14 ans
sur des gens adultes
avec des grosses voitures.
SQ : Vous trouvez ça génial,
vous n’avez pas peur ?
LP : Il y a une sorte de coquetterie et
de choc générationnel qui font que non,
moi, le petit sans un rond,
je t’emmène où il faut en toute sécurité.
Par la suite, j’ai réalisé que
j’avais fait une erreur aussi,
c’est de ne pas avoir
rassuré mes passagers.
Et ça m’a énormément servi.
J’ai toujours fait en équipage
en sorte que toute mon équipe,
à terre comme en mer,
soit rassurée en permanence.
C’est intéressant,
les erreurs que l’on fait.
SQ : Donc, ils sont dans la cabine.
LP : Oui et ils restent,
puis on arrive à bon port,
et la carte bleue va enfin servir
pour rentrer à la maison.
Le plus marrant,
c’est qu’ils étaient convaincus,
et je pense que beaucoup
de Terriens le sont,
que le problème se règle avec
un hélico ou la Marine nationale
qui, heureusement,
vient parfois nous aider.
Ça, c’est vrai, mais il y a des moments
on est très loin de tout,
loin des hommes et des femmes
de cette planète.
C’est ça aussi la belle leçon de vie de
la mer, c’est qu’on ne peut pas dire stop.
On ne peut pas acheter le fait d'arrêter.
Le meilleur moyen de s’arrêter en mer,
c’est de continuer.
Je pense que ces gens-là, ces adultes
certainement très vieux maintenant,
ont dû se souvenir toute leur vie
de ce moment assez étonnant.
SQ : Continuer, ça veut dire que
vous n’avez jamais eu envie ou un soupçon
d’envie d’abandonner ?
LP : Non, l’abandon, non.
Il a été malheureusement forcé par
des fortunes de mer, des démâtages
et pas mal d’autres choses, des bateaux
qui coulent ou chavirent -
chavirer ne m’est jamais arrivé.
Par contre, je me suis juré
1000 fois par transat
de ne plus jamais refaire
de transat en solitaire.
Ça, c’est étonnant, même si c’est le
propre du genre humain, bizarrement,
de vite oublier les souffrances vécues
pour retourner dans le même enfer.
On le voit très bien malheureusement
dans le domaine des guerres,
et dans d’autres domaines.
L’amnésie est un sport mondial
dont j’aimerais bien que le président,
sauf que les membres oublieraient de payer
leur cotisation, c’est le problème.
C’est assez étonnant ça.
Je sais que je me souviens m’être
juré vraiment des centaines de fois
par transatlantique en solitaire,
particulièrement,
parce que c’est vraiment le domaine
le plus stressant,
et j’en ai enchaîné quelques-unes,
quand même.
Car la beauté de ce métier, cette passion,
ne consiste pas seulement
à la partie émergée de l’iceberg,
la partie de la navigation entre
les lignes de départ et d’arrivée.
C’est tout ce qui précède
ou tout ce qui va suivre,
de la conception d’un bateau,
d’une équipe,
de vendre son projet,
son rêve, son produit,
puisqu’on est tous des produits
à vendre sur un marché.
Et jusqu’à une ligne d’arrivée éventuelle.
L’autre beauté de notre métier, on l’a vu
sur le Vendée Globe, on l’a évoqué,
c’est qu’on a cette chance de ne pas être
obligé de gagner pour réussir.
C'est l'un des rares sports aventure
qui nous permet ça.
Donc, à chaque non-victoire,
c’est toujours
une motivation complémentaire
pour essayer d’y retourner.
SQ : Je me demande quand même
si ça se travaille, si ça s’acquiert,
parce qu’il y a évidemment de l’inné
dans cette façon de vivre sans filet,
cette confiance.
Est-ce qu’on peut avoir quand même
des trucs, des astuces pour acquérir
cette vision des choses de la vie,
sans filet ?
Par exemple, vous préparez-vous,
y a-t-il de la préparation physique -
c’est assez costaud -
est-ce que ça s’accompagne ?
LP : On voit bien que
ce n’est pas mon fort justement.
Nos préparations consistent en général
à gommer des lacunes
dans tous les domaines,
ou à parfaire nos qualités,
mais surtout à gommer les lacunes.
J’ai quelques phrases à l’emporte-pièce
comme ça, mais qui sont importantes.
En solitaire, on ne peut pas
être bon partout, nulle part d’ailleurs.
Mais on n’a pas le droit
d’être mauvais quelque part.
Ça veut dire que quand on est
tout seul sur un bateau,
qu’on a théoriquement vraisemblablement
conçu en équipage, en équipe,
on connaît d’un bout à l’autre la totalité
du bateau, mais pas seulement.
Il faut savoir coudre, se nourrir,
réparer, faire de la météo,
de l’informatique, de l’électronique,
avoir évidemment
des connaissances en physique.
C’est un métier extrêmement
complet dans ce domaine.
Et il y a quelques lacunes qui,
physiquement, ne serait-ce que ça -
J’ai eu un challenge extrêmement compliqué
lors de l’avant-dernière Route du Rhum
il y a 8 ans, quand au pied levé, on m’a
demandé de remplacer Armel Le Cléac’h
sur l’un des plus gros trimarans du monde
après 12 ans d’interruption.
Ma première réponse, quand on m’a
demandé de le faire, c’était non.
Puis la deuxième, après une nuit de
réflexion était : « Oui, pourquoi pas ? »
Parce que tout est faisable dès qu’on
connaît bien ses faiblesses, bizarrement.
On entretient ses qualités,
il faut certes se connaître.
Beaucoup de visualisation.
SQ : Voilà, c’est ça.
LP : C’est étonnant, depuis tout petit,
je rêve beaucoup, c’est vrai.
Petit, on rêve, on bricole,
on fait des Légo, du mécano.
Et plus tard, on n’est pas toujours
en train d’assouvir tous ses rêves.
Heureusement car ce n’en serait plus
et ce n’est pas plus mal d’en cultiver.
Et il y a cette faculté,
je crois qu’on partage la même chose,
de visualiser.
Quand on se retrouve du jour au lendemain
sur l’un des plus grands trimarans
avec 40 ficelles, sur lequel
on n’a jamais navigué,
qu’on a 54 piges, un physique
pas vraiment à la hauteur du défi,
Il faut qu’intellectuellement,
on ait une grande confiance
et l’une des manières
que j’aime bien faire,
naturellement, c'est de visualiser
toutes les manœuvres constamment.
C’est compliqué - la moindre
manœuvre sur un bateau comme ça,
c’est à peu près une petite heure,
trois quarts d’heure, d’effort continu.
Comme je ne suis pas très costaud,
c’est encore un peu plus long
que ceux qui sont des vrais sportifs.
Il y avait un vélo sur ce bateau-là,
un vélo connecté au winch
car mes jambes étaient un peu
moins faibles que les bras.
Mais un challenge génial,
assez passionnant.
SQ : Depuis votre plus tendre
enfance, vous visualisez ?
Vous savez qu’il y a des livres
de développement personnel.
LP : Je ne les ai pas écrits moi-même.
C’est vrai ?
Mais c’est pas mal.
Mais c’est bien de faire de la prose
sans le savoir, comme Monsieur Jourdain,
il y a plein de choses comme ça
qu’on n’est pas obligé d’apprendre
dans les livres.
C’est certes intéressant de s’en inspirer.
Je sais que les nouvelles générations
de marins, aujourd’hui,
et depuis pas mal d’années,
se mettent des électrodes sur
la tête pour analyser leur sommeil.
Le sommeil, c’est l’arme du solitaire,
c’est le truc le plus important.
Tout le monde arrive à dormir ici,
mais pas mal de gens, malheureusement,
ont du mal à s’endormir.
Je vous explique ce qu’il se passe,
sur un multicoque en solitaire.
On va cinq fois plus vite
qu’un bateau normal.
Le stress de la vitesse,
c’est quand même un peu hostile.
Le fait est aussi qu’un trimaran,
ou un catamaran,
est plus stable à l’envers qu’à l’endroit,
c’est embêtant, mais c’est ainsi,
et ça met 10 secondes à chavirer.
Donc le tableau est comme ça :
la mer, le bruit, un bateau
qui vole au-dessus de l’eau,
plus effrayant en termes de vitesse,
mais paradoxalement plus confortable
car il tape moins dans les vagues.
Ce qui est intéressant,
c’est qu’on cherche à dormir.
Il faut impérativement dormir,
sinon on se retrouve vraiment
en grande difficulté de fatigue.
L’endormissement, on a presque
un sentiment de culpabilité
quand on s’endort.
Un, on se met en danger.
Deux, on va moins vite car on a réduit
la pression sur les voiles
pour éviter de chavirer.
Et trois, on ignore si deux ou
trois kilomètres devant nous,
il n'y a pas un cargo.
On a quelques systèmes de sécurité,
des filets justement,
qui heureusement existent.
Et tout ça fait que, eh bien, il faut
réussir à dormir 20 minutes,
à s’endormir le plus vite possible.
Ça, c'est un exercice de dingue.
Et on peut analyser les choses
en faisant des électrodes.
Ce que je n’ai jamais fait,
car depuis tout petit, je fais ça.
J’ai cette chance de d’avoir
une progression un peu naturelle
et une obligation de pouvoir m’endormir
partout, n’importe où, n’importe quand.
SQ : C’est ce qui fait votre aisance,
quand moi je vous ai vu
combien de fois en pleine mer,
parler de votre expérience,
de ce que vous étiez en train de vivre
avec une aisance et un naturel,
un sourire, une répartie.
C’est ça,
c’est Loïck Peyron dans le texte ?
LP : Non, il y a une petite particularité
peut-être, assez française d’ailleurs,
C’est un univers hostile
qui est vraiment très violent -
je parle de la vitesse -
Je vais faire un petit aparté là-dessus.
On comprend tous la vitesse en voiture,
ce que ça peut être, d’accord.
On est tous des conducteurs, il n’y a pas
de pilote, j’imagine, dans la salle.
Je ne suis pas pilote.
j’ai fait des courses de voitures,
mais je ne m’estime pas pilote.
Avec les notions de vitesse,
on ne sait pas à quoi ça correspond.
On comprend bien que si je dis
à un pilote de Formule 1
que moi aussi j’ai une voiture,
il s’en fout un peu.
Mais par contre, bizarrement,
dans le milieu voile,
tous les gens qui ont la chance
de faire du bateau en compétition,
s'estiment dans la même famille.
C'est assez bizarre.
Ce qui est assez étonnant c’est que
les Terriens - ce n’est pas péjoratif -
nous sommes tous beaucoup plus
impressionnés par la durée en mer
que par la vitesse en mer.
Je reprends l’exemple du Vendée Globe,
il y a autant de monde,
et vous avez peut-être plus retenu
le nom du dernier que celui du premier.
Je disais qu’on n’est pas obligé
de gagner pour réussir,
le Vendée Globe en est la preuve.
Tous les quatre ans, on a des histoires
et des générations et des personnalités
qui se révèlent sur la durée.
Mais bizarrement, les Terriens sont
beaucoup plus impressionnés
par la souffrance éventuelle
de celui qui va finir dernier.
Pas du tout : il va doucement.
C’est très facile d’aller
doucement sur l’eau.
Difficile d'aller vite.
SQ : Loïck, vous disiez « sans filet »,
et je n’y croyais qu’à moitié.
Je n’y crois toujours qu’à moitié,
car en fait, quand même,
vous avez positionné tout ce qu’il faut
pour vivre sans filet.
LP : Mais fort heureusement,
j’essaye de les créer moi-même.
J’en reviens à cette histoire-là.
On est dans une grande difficulté,
on en parle dans tous les domaines,
dans l’entreprise,
la politique ou la gestion.
Ce qui commence vraiment à peser beaucoup
sur notre société au sens large,
et sur le bateau en particulier,
eh bien, c’est justement le fait
qu’on nous impose des filets
basés sur une statistique normale basse,
sur l’utilisateur moyen.
Ce que je veux dire n’est pas péjoratif,
mais on est obligé d’essayer
de s’intéresser à tout le monde
et ça devient compliqué.
J’ai un dernier petit exemple.
J’ai eu la chance de passer
et de recevoir mon permis côtier -
il y a quelques années, il était temps -
pour avoir le droit de faire
du bateau à moteur
à plus de 6 milles des côtes, à 12 km.
Et puis mon petit frère
qui se met au bateau à moteur.
Pour aller à La Banche, c’est le phare
là-bas, à côté des éoliennes,
on le verra de moins en moins ;
on ne verra plus que les éoliennes,
et en tout cas pour aller là-bas,
près des éoliennes,
vous n’avez pas le droit
d’y aller d’ailleurs,
il faut un permis hauturier,
ce n’est pas la même chose.
Donc le côtier vous permet d’aller
à 6 milles, après, vous êtes morts.
Si vous n’avez pas de permis,
inévitablement, ça doit être dangereux.
Donc moi, après 5 ans de transat
et 4 tours du monde,
il a fallu que je m’emmerde un peu
et je n’ai pas eu tout bon.
Je vous rassure, parce que
c’est très, très con, ce permis,
ça ne sert absolument à rien.
Ce sont les vieilles manières
de naviguer d’il y a 30 ans
qui était relativement pratiques
avant le GPS.
Aucun intérêt.
Personne ne va vous apprendre
par contre à manœuvrer,
à rentrer dans un port avec un bateau
avec un mât, des voiles.
Une aberration absolue, intéressante
d’une réglementation pondue par des...
peu importe, voilà...
Vous avez tous compris
ce que je voulais dire.
SQ : Visiblement, merci beaucoup Loïck.
LP : Merci à vous,
bonne journée quand même.
SQ : Merci.
(Applaudissements)